now one Democratic congressman who
actually voted to impeach Donald Trump
also blasted Bellows writing quote we
are nation of laws therefore until Trump
is actually found guilty of the crime of
insurrection which is not going to
happen he should be allowed on the
ballot now make no mistake this creates
a dangerous new president that will come
back to haunt the Democratic party but
we do hope Sheena Bellow enjoys her 15
minutes of fame I don't know if I hope
she does but here now with more Fox News
contributor former house Speaker Speaker
of the House of course n Gingrich
speaker Gingrich thank you so much for
being with me tonight you know your
experience speaks for itself uh and your
Insight about the nature of all the
things that we've seen in this country
is invaluable but this has really with
all the things we would have expected of
the left and of the Democrats this
really does jump the shark if you will
tell me your thoughts on what we've been
experiencing well I I think we need to
refocus on what's Happening there's too
much talk about the war against Trump uh
this is not a war against Trump this is
a war against the American people uh you
see that with Robert F Kennedy Jr who's
talked about the fact that the left
wants an oligarchy to run everything and
they won't allow him to compete right uh
you see it if you talk to the people at
No Labels uh who've been working very
hard to obey the rules and may well be
on all 50 ballots and in every state
they've had Democrats try to keep them
off the ballot and think about it the
attack in Colorado is not on Donald
Trump the attacks on the mil 300,000
coloradans who voted for him the attack
in Maine is not on Donald Trump he
carried the Northern District of Maine
so this is an attack on every person in
the Northern District of Maine and I
think we need to be very clear you know
if you're Jewish you probably shouldn't
be too open about it at Harvard or
Colombia because you'll get punished
uh if you actually believe that there
are only two Sexes you probably
shouldn't say it too openly cuz you'll
get punished and go down the list you
have a totalitarian left and the assault
on the American people they cannot
survive if you have a free and fair
election and so they are devoting huge
amounts of money I mean if if we had a
news media worthy of the effort they
would be out right now finding out from
Soros to every other left-wing group how
much money is being ped into trying to
radically change this country and the
numbers would be staggering and all of
it isn't an attack on Donald J Trump
it's an attack on the American people he
happens to be the vehicle for their
desire for real change but what they're
terrified of is not just Trump it's the
underlying nature of the American people
and their desire for a patriotic country
based on solid values excellent point
because obviously if you can't vote for
the person that you like that is the
strike at the individual engaged in this
process separate from Donald Trump that
it is about what we understand our
system to be about this Republic we have
and about us being the boss and making
these choices so you know we know a left
we speak about funding we know a
leftwing group funded the lawsuit it was
a case uh that got to the Colorado
Supreme Court and of course Maine there
was no case this was just a declaration
uh and there are more States considering
doing this this also happened when we
still had three Democrats on that
Colorado Supreme Court descent now that
makes me feel that there is some hope
that there are Democrats who are also
seeing this as a problem what do you
make of that because this clearly seems
to be organized uh by something larger
than each state
alone well I look that's clear there's a
nationwide leftwing movement of radicals
who want open borders they want to
abolish teaching American history they
want to impose on uh second third and
fourth graders a series of sexual
choices that most people think is
irrational just go down the list and
these people are all connected to each
other they're all funded by people like
Soros they're all funded by the Ford
foundation and a whole range of other
the elites collectively want to somehow
radically change America and subordinate
it to a larger global system and they're
doing everything they can the New York
Times is sort of their CH primary
cheerleader The Washington Post is a
secondary cheerleader but these folks
all are determined to destroy the
America that you and I grew up in and
replace it with a remarkably different
country and part of what's happening is
and Trump happens to be the person who
polarizes it but what's happening is
huge numbers of Americans are saying
enough and the result is I think uh that
the Democrats are now in increasing
trouble because they're so clearly uh
the party of outrageous anti-American
Behavior you know this is what's
striking though as well is I guess it's
just that they've continually
underestimate the American people or
really have a contempt for the nature of
maybe not in LA and and New York but in
that great middle space of of a nation
that has saved the world many times over
the people who live in anonymity work
hard you know Farm create things run
production and are quiet about it it it
seems and this is heartening as well
that those individuals are constantly
underestimated uh and spat upon by The
Cosmopolitan Elite in this
country well you you had two great
examples and I'm trying to remember the
word you'll remember it the Hillary's
term for all the rest of us irredeemable
too conservative to understand
irredeemable irredeemable and then
remember remember Barack Obama had a
fundraiser in San Francisco talking
about small towns in Pennsylvania where
people cling to their guns and their
Bible that's right I mean the level of
contempt for everyday Americans was
astonishing and by the way that has
further polarized the country uh and I
think you're going to see the left
become a smaller and smaller part of the
American scene well that is perhaps one
of the Silver Linings here this is going
to this had to happen and I'm lucky that
you're here with us and thank you very
much for your Insight sir hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else